dass musik jahrzehnt bedeutet für mich
wie wiederauferstehung des deutschrap
sie elektronische musik und hip hop
lösen
rockmusik als die leitende kultur des
jahrzehnts ab es gibt nicht mehr den
hiphop oder den rap irgendwie bedient
sich jeder an jedem stand die musik in
dem diesen jetzt fehlt eigentlich auch
besonders schön weil sie so sehr
ausdrucksstark waren es ist es ein sehr
politisches jahrzehnte auch musikalisch
gewesen gerade diese migrantische kultur
die noch mal eine ganz neue melodischen
ansatz in diese musik rein gebracht hat
ich halte es eher mit dendemann der sagt
dass es noch nie so viele gut
produzierte musik gegeben hat in
irgendwelchen kellerstudio es gibt
unglaublich viele starke frauen crêpes
und club musik vereinbart und dann
vermischt noch irgendwas neues dazu und
dann entsteht so was wie schlager
redmann hat seine songs nicht mehr
unbedingt zur gitarre spielen müssen um
eine aussage zu treffen
deswegen war das ein unglaublich
produktive 14
[Musik]
also mich ist der fall muss jetzt sehen
stecken auch von taylor swift
und zwar habe ich das lied ultra oft in
meinem auslandssemester in rom gehört
und auch heute schreiben wir aus also
freunde aus dem auslandssemester
manchmal einfach noch kommentare take it
off und ich finde es eigentlich ganz
gute erinnerung daran dass man sich
nicht immer so viel gedanken darum
machen sollte was andere über einen
denken airplanes ist ein gutes beispiel
für einen wahnsinnig kitschige popsong
der nur in kombination mit einem
ziemlich guten hip hop beat aufgeht und
den ich mir mit anfang 20 nur zu mögen
erlaubt habe weil er in einer ziemlich
guten rap tradition steht jetzt kommt
meine lieblingsstelle klimakiller wusste
ich musste checken maschine sagte sie
[Musik]
die stelle ist ist so gut einfach dieser
dialog in dem song liebe ich habe den
song song zweimal live gehört wie dann
tatsächlich alle aufgestanden sind
mitgewippt haben mit gerappt haben
mitgesungen haben sollen gänsehaut
moment und ich erinnere mich tatsächlich
acht jahre später immer noch sehr gut an
diesem moment sonntag
ja das ist also ein so tolles lied man
kann's gar nicht ausstellen weil das ein
total mit drei ist unglaublich was der
flora da geleistet hat man weiß ja web
kann auch sehr langweilig sein
es gibt ja so leute wie drake oder auch
hier in deutschland so sachen wie tritt
man oder sowas kann man so sehen wenn
man sich nicht auskennt wie alfons
kaiser in diesem fall aber wenn alfons
kaiser mal auf ein konzert von tritt man
gehen würde dann würde er sehen dass es
da wahrscheinlich zehn mal mehr abgeht
als auf diesen komischen ami rapper den
er da vergöttert
wenn erschleichen um den block machen
geschäft mit der hoffnung
was also das lied grauer beton von
trentmann ist auf den ersten blick ein
sehr trostloses lied auch wenn man sich
das video anschaut alles schwarz weiß
blau chemnitz aber genau darum geht es
eben auch weil er von seiner jugend
erzählt dass in chemnitz aufgewachsen im
plattenbau und erzählt dass die leute
dort vergessen wurden anfang der 90er
jahre und dann könnte man sagen warum
macht das jetzt das lied zu einem
wichtigen nicht in diesem jahrzehnt aber
tatsächlich erklärt dass sehr viel was
in diesem jahrzehnt in deutschland vor
allem in ostdeutschland passiert ist im
hintergrund zieht hat bis zum 1
ja bis zu drei von warpaint habe ich
gehört
und das ist ein song wie ein gedicht
jetzt zieht sich komplett rein und ich
hatte ein kleines aha erlebnis als ich
mir live anschauen wollte und ich bei
youtube mir das video angeschaut habe
und gedacht habe das sind ja nur frauen
dass ich das überhaupt bemerkt habe weil
es ist eigentlich ganz normal dass
frauen auch instrumente spielen
ich kannte aber bis dahin hauptsächlich
bands in denen männer diese instrumente
auf diese art und weise bedienen also
handgemachte musik sozusagen rockmusik
in die alternative
[Musik]
ja die aufgabe das beste lied der
zehnerjahre auszuwählen war super
schwierig das sortiment entdeckt so vor
34 jahren und habe dann lange gebraucht
dass ich sie tatsächlich mal live
gesehen habe das erste mal war ein
offenbach dann habe ich sie in diesem
jahr auf der bühne erlebt draußen im
palmengarten in frankfurt und das waren
wirklich ein magischer abend ein lauer
sommerabend an am ende man bestimmt 200
leute an diesem wenn dieser warmen
sommernacht vor der bühne habe zu dieser
gar nicht so leicht tanzbaren musik aber
da für sich selbst getanzt und das war
eine fantastische atmosphäre
ich suche
[Musik]
alsfeld bittet cas